Speaker 1: Speaking of threats,
Congressman Matt Gaetz, who continues to be
at risk of being charged for a number of different
things, including possibly trafficking a minor,
a sex trafficking, a minor he gave a very strange.
Each on the floor of the House on Wednesday,
where he said he thinks someone may be
trying to kill him. And let's take let's
take a listen to what he had to say.
Speaker 2: I'd like to yield first two
minutes to my colleague from Florida
Rep. Syndicate's without objection.
Speaker 3: I thank the gentleman for yielding
because I think someone may be trying to kill me.
And if they are successful, I would
like my constituents and my family
to know who stopped their arrest. Madam
Speaker, on October 8th, 2021, a Twitter handle
styled CIA bob is at your door tweeted to at Rep.
Matt Gaetz. Looky here, pal. I lived in Portland.
Portland has ordered a hit on you. I accepted the
contract. Have a good day! Following this tweet,
this individual traveled to Washington, D.C.,
and the Capitol Police recommended his arrest.
That's information that was just shared with me by
the Investigations and Threat Assessment section
of the Protective Services Bureau.
And specifically, George DiCenzo and
George shared with me that the Capitol Police
recommended the arrest of this individual and
that the Department of Justice refused to do so.
Declined to do so. And on the eve of the attorney
general testifying before the Judiciary Committee
tomorrow, it is just yet another example of the
Department of Justice having a double standard.
Speaker 1: So we don't know how much of this
is true. If someone threatened him on Twitter
and then flew across, presuming it's Portland,
Oregon flew across the country to Washington,
D.C., that individual should be arrested. If
the individual wasn't arrested and everything else
is true, we should know why. If the Department of
Justice said, don't arrest, we should know
why. But imagine if the floor of the House
was taken over by members announcing every
threat that they get on Twitter. You know,
there's so many questions here, including whether
Gates is even telling the truth about this. But
in all seriousness, often death threats are not
something you want to announce publicly because
it encourages way more of them. I told this
story once, long after it took place of someone
who had been sending me threats, and I didn't
mention anything about it at the time for years.
I ultimately learned that the FBI went to the
House of this individual and it was someone living
very rurally the way it was described
by the FBI. It was an extremely, oh man,
I don't want to be insulting. But the FBI said
this is someone without the resources or volition
to carry out the threats. And imagine if all along
I had been announcing the fact that this threat
was going on and it ended up being a particular
threat of no consequence or significance at all.
But all the time people are hearing about it and
it's encouraging copycats, and it's encouraging
more threats and that type of thing. I just
don't know other than grandstanding and other
than trying to make some statement of political
bias that the Department of Justice only wants
to protect Democrats from death threats and not
Republicans or something like that. I don't even
know why this is being discussed on the floor
of the House. And of course, in the meantime,
understand that Matt Gaetz is under investigation
by federal authorities for sex crimes. That's
really what the focus should be, and I read
one comment that said he's just already trying
to argue that federal authorities have a bias
against him, too, if he is indeed charged by
those same departments, if the DOJ ultimately
charges him. He can come in and maybe try to use
this as a defense. Listen, they these people have
it out for me. When we reported a death threat
and that Capitol Police said the person should be
arrested, they didn't even do it. I don't know if
Matt Gaetz has that amount of foresight. Maybe
it's his lawyers. I don't know. It's certainly
plausible, but not something. We actually have
evidence as the motivation for him doing this.
But a very strange declaration to be making
on the floor of the House, both for security
reasons about not publicizing threats and because
of the fact that he's currently being investigated
by federal authorities for a bunch of different,
pretty serious crimes. Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We'll
take a break. And we have a lot coming up for you
today. Remember that the David Pakman show is
made possible primarily by viewers and listeners
who sign up on our website and get themselves
a membership members memberships are cheap.
They're easy to sign up for, takes about a minute
with average computer skills, and you get access
to great stuff like the bonus show, commercial
free streams of the show on and on. You can sign
up at join Packman dot com and if you want a
discount, you can use the coupon code better. 21.